Bông bông bắt động sản người chẻ trẻ dài trước sức mơ ăn cửa,
tự tế cho thời, Việt Nam đang đứng trước quyết cơ thửa,
nhưng người gli là rất nhiều người chẻ vẫn không thể mua nổi.
Chúng tịch sân lúc vừa kinh báo,
thì chương bắt động sản đăng bông nổ với hàng luật xưa đuí đuí đuí sây dân
nhưng phần lớn lại gắn và nông vi khảm dầu có,
chỉ dương quy mốt của quà có hôm mười bố niệm gặp chăng cân nổ mới nước tục ra thì chương.
Nhưng đến năm 2019 là cân hộ cao vấp hoặc học sang,
trong khi đó nhà ở bình dân và nhà ở sã hội chỉ chỉ mười bạo phần chăm,
chưa đến 2 yên cân một con số quán nhỏ sau với lúc cầu tục tế.
Tất đen khỏng năm năm, chương gửa hả nổ chỉ dạo đốc quay mức bố
mấy chục đồng trên mơ bếp vông,
bây giờ mức dã Trung bình đã tăng lên từ bệm mười để mốt chăng chục đồng trên mơ bếp vông,
thành phố hồ chỉ mềm cũng không kém,
dã Trung cơ hiệm đã ở mức Trung bếng bếm bếm mốt phẩy tán chục đồng trên mơ bếp vông,
tăng tế bán biến lắm phần chăm trong năm năm qua,
ra nhận này cả cao nhưng tu nhập của người chế lại không tăng theo kìp,
nhà thì tu ở mơ người chế vẫn chẳng giả mơ tới một chún ăn cơ,
chức đầy đã có những cú đồ thịt được sây dâm tộn dự bỏ hoang,
liệu có sáng nghiệp bất tộng sản Việt Nam có đang đi vào vết sê đồ,
dự án móc lên, như dân không về sống,
liều này sẽ dẫn đến hệ quả tỷ cho tỷ chương,
bạn có sản sản mùa nhà với ra cao,
hãy sẽ chở bóng bóng bóng vớ,
hãy để lại ý kiêm cú bát sử dụng như thế?